تعود حادثه التسريب من خطي انابيب الغاز
الروسيين نور الدين واحد ونور الدين اثنين
الى الواجهه من جديد مع تاكيد المدعي
العام السويدي تعرضهما لعمل تخريبي متعمد
بعد العثور على اثار مواد متفجره قرب
الخطاين داخل المياه الاقليميه السويديه
في بحر البلطيق بحسب المدعي العام السويدي
فان هذه النتائج جاءت اثره تحقيق شامل
ومعقد للغايه استمر لاسابيع الاعلان
السويدي السرعان ما تلقفه لكريم مبديا
ترحيبه بخلاصه تحقيقات ستوكه معتبرا ان
فرضيه الهجوم الارهابي تؤكد مصداقيه
المعلومات الروسيه داعيا الى تحديد الجهه
المسؤوله عن التفجير وسبق للسلطات
الدنماركيه ان صرحت الشهر الماضي بان
تحقيقاتها الاوليه اظهرت ان سبب تسريبات
في الخطين اللذين كنال مصدر الاهم للغازي
الروسي الى اوروبا هو انفجارات قويه حادثه
التسريب كانت قد كشفت في السادس والعشرين
من سبتمبر الماضي بعد انخفاض سريعا وغير
متوقع للضغط في انابيب الغاز المتوقفه عن
العمل حينها منذ نهايه اغسطس الماضي
ليتبين لاحقا ظهور اربع فجوات في خطين
وردسترين واحد واثنين داخل المياه
الاقليميه لكل من السويد والدنمارك تبادلت
حينها كل من روسيا والدول الغربيه
الاتهامات بشان المسؤوليه عن التفجير في
حين رجحت الاستخبارات الالمانيه ان يكون
غواصونا وضعوا عبوات متفجره على مسار
الانبوب موسكو التي وصفت انا ذاك
الاتهامات الغربيه بالغربيه والسخيفه قالت
الشهر الماضي ان افرادا من البحريه
البريطانيه فجروا خطي الانابيب وهو اتهام
وصفته لندن بانه زائف ويهدف الى في
الانتباه عن الاخفاقات العسكريه الروسيه
في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]